- Good morning Believe Nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe,
and I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of
the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn how
to build a great team.
Over to you Kandi Burruss.
(shouting rooster)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- It's always good is
if you can get somebody
to partner up with you
and with other businesses.
Because for me, I have a business partner
with tags in my stores, I have a business
partner with Bedroom Kandi.
If it wasn't for that, I wouldn't be able
to do all the things that I'm doin'.
But because I do have
great business partners,
they help me keep those things going.
So you have to have a great team.
You by yourself, it
probably wouldn't work.
You can't be but in so
many places at one time,
so you have to have
people to see your vision
and help make your vision happen.
- You can't do everything yourself
if you want to be a
successful entrepreneur.
There are only so many hours in a day
and you only have so much limited ability,
that if you try to do everything
in your business and never look to scale
or grow, then you're going to be limited
in how much you can do and
how much you can accomplish.
Now at the start, you
do everything yourself.
At the start, you boost up,
you hustle, you find ways.
But quickly, you need to figure out what
is a thing that you are
among the best people
in the world at or have
that world-class potential?
You are genius-level talent at something.
What is that?
Figure that out and spend as much time
in that lane as possible, and then look
to expand by building up people who
are great at all the
things you're not good at.
Here are a couple of the pitfalls
that people falter when they
go through this process.
First off, rarely the first person
that you hire is a good fit.
They may have the skills that you want,
but your values don't align, right?
You don't have similar one words,
you haven't gone through that process,
your values don't align
and so it falls apart.
You also likely suck as a leader.
Part of now building a team
is you need to lead a team.
You need to be a good manager,
you have to care about your people
and not just about them
getting the work done,
but care about them as human beings
and what they're going through
and how you can help, and how
you can be supportive to them.
So a lot of times, that
first hire doesn't work out.
And here's what happens
to so many entrepreneurs.
That person didn't work out, I can't build
a team, that was a stupid idea,
I'm just going to go back
to doing everything myself
because it was so much easier.
And then you end up playing small again.
So what ends up happening when you hire
is they take up a lot of your time,
there's a learning
curve, they may have some
problems at the beginning.
But by working through
that and maybe getting rid
of them and bringing somebody else in,
work it through that
getting the right people
in place, that's when you can go
and explode and do much
more meaningful work,
spend your time doing the things
that make you a lot more excited,
and have a much bigger impact.
A lot of people also
say, well I don't have
the money to go out and hire somebody,
I can't afford to go
out and hire somebody.
How am I going to build a team?
I can't even pay myself.
Well, a couple ideas.
One, you don't necessarily need
to hire somebody right now.
As long as it's on your roadmap,
as long as it's something
that you're constantly
paying attention to that is in your vision
so that you are not going
to be doing this alone
for the rest of your life.
Two, you can look at hiring somebody
on a part-time basis.
The first person I hired
was for one hour a day,
one hour a day doing database work
for me because he was
better at it than I was
and he freed up an hour and a half
of my time to go off and do other things
that I enjoyed more and I was better at
and could help build the business.
So you could hire somebody for an hour
a day or a couple of hours a week just
to free up some of that work
that you don't want to do
to focus on bigger things.
And three, you can also look for people
to volunteer or to be a part.
It might be a partnership in your business
and you're both putting sweat equity in.
It might be mentoring somebody who
is a high school intern
or a university intern
and bringing them into your business.
Now you have to do your job
of actually mentoring them,
but they're looking
more for the experience
of being involved in
what you're doing than
for monetary compensation, right?
They're getting a grade at their school,
so they have to do a good job and that's
what they're looking for, much more
than getting paid to do it.
So there's always other options,
and one of the most important things
that you need to understand
as an entrepreneur
is you need to be resourceful.
You will get these kinds
of problems, constantly.
I need to bring on a
team, but I can't afford
to do it, how do I do that?
I need to go and market my company,
but I can't afford to take
out an ad on the Super Bowl,
so how do I go and do that, right?
You will constantly
have these restrictions
and restraints that are put on you
as you try to build the business.
You are constantly lacking in resources
and so, you succeed by being resourceful,
by finding another way, by being creative,
by understanding people and what they need
and how you might be
able to give it to them
in a non-monetary way.
That's the game of entrepreneurship.
I was able to greatly
expand my businesses,
my YouTube channel, since that's
what you may be more familiar with.
At the beginning it was me doing videos
all by myself, and I would make a video
at most once a week,
but usually maybe once
a month or twice a month.
And then as I brought my
first editor on-board,
that's when I was able to go from once
a week max to once a day.
That was a huge increase right?
Seven times or more.
And then when I got a second editor,
when I got researchers I can move up,
and I went to two a day
and went to three a day.
And so you can greatly
improve your productivity
by building the team and I get to focus
on what I love doing.
I don't like editing.
That's not what I love,
Christina loves editing.
Christina's editing this video,
you know I love you Christina.
Christina loves editing,
it's what she loves
to do and what she's great at.
It's amazing.
I love being in front of the camera
and it's the highest value
that I can bring to the team.
If it relied on me being a great editor,
this company would fail.
'Cause it's not something
that I actually want
to learn to get better at.
There's this old saying,
if you want to go far,
you go with the team.
If you want to go fast, you go alone.
And so stop focusing
on the short-term game
of just going fast, think
long-term, think bigger-picture,
think going far, think about the vision,
think about what you're
trying to accomplish.
You need a team to help you get there.
So the question then today is,
I'm curious, who was the first person
that you hired on your
team that added incremental
improvement and you
saw big business growth
because of it, or if
you haven't hired yet,
who is the first person that you need
on your team to be able to blast through?
Really curious to find out, leave
it down in the comments below.
I also want to give a quick shout-out
to coach Bailey Cooper from
canvassingcoachaustintx.com.
Thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word.
I really, really, really
appreciate the support
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Over the next five years, we plan
to take on the banking community,
we plan to take on the cosmetics industry,
we plan to take on the clothing industry
and telecommunications, and
one or two other industries
and see whether we can give them
a run for their money and
do it slightly differently
than it's been done before.
- Why do you think you can do it?
- Mainly because I think we've got
a fantastic team of people.
We attract good people.
- And their skills are translatable
to whatever the industry is.
It's creativity, it's risk
orientation, it's what?
- I think if you can
run one business well,
you can run any business.
And if you know that what matters
in business is a good team of people,
well-motivated team of
people, incentivized well,
given a lot of freedom to go out
and prove themselves, you can
pretty well achieve anything.
- [Interviewer] What do you
credit for your success?
- I mean you got to have a great team.
It's all about having the
right people around you.
- Surprised, surprised by
the night of turn-up, whoa.
♫ Whoa, it's just me, myself, and I.
- Both for solid workers, but
also just positive influences
to you, you know what I mean?
People that inspire you, people who bring
good energy every day.
That and just hardworking dedication.
- You sound so passionate
about so many diverse pieces
of your life that the big question is,
how do you juggle all that?
How do you make all of that
happen and successfully
from your music career to being a mom,
to being a life partner, all of that
is so hard to juggle, how do you do it?
What's the secret behind that?
- I don't know how I'm
going to keep doin' it.
That's a good question.
'Cause with a baby, things
tend to change a lot,
but I have a great team,
people who understand me
very well who understand my cause,
my commitment, and who support him
and make my life easier.
So it is very important
to be well-surrounded.